voilà pour la situation à Kiev ce lundi
bonjour Jean-Paul Palomeros et merci de
répondre à FRANCE 24 vous êtes ancien
chef d'état-major de l'armée de l'air
ancien commandant suprême des forces
alliés de l'OTAN
keV et pour l'heure toujours aux mains
des
Ukrainiens la Russie a pourtant
clairement les moyens de prendre la
capitale ukrainienne comment vous
expliquer cette cette situation
alors elle a les moyens de prendre la
capitale ukrainienne c'est je pense
qu'on peut pas tout à fait dire les
choses comme ça
elle a sans doute elle a les moyens de
frapper KEPS pas ce typiquement
d'ailleurs des crimes de guerre il faut
le souligner et elle a elle a les moyens
de faire mal ça c'est sûr elle peut
encercler kievs en gros c'est ce qu'elle
est en train de faire peut-être qu'elle
terminera cet encerclement de là à
rentrer elle peut rentrer dans Kiev sur
des objectifs précis
qui sera qui sera en particulier le
pouvoir déstabiliser le pouvoir
et mais de là a vraiment prendre ok au
sens propre du terme ça c'est une autre
paire de manches il faut beaucoup
beaucoup plus de monde beaucoup plus de
soldats de militaires pour prendre une
ville de cette nature que ceux qui sont
engagés aujourd'hui je suis certain que
la Russie les ai
est-ce que selon vous Poutine va
développer la même stratégie à Kiev que
dans les autres grandes villes où les
bombardements détruisent constamment les
immeubles les civils même si on a vu que
ce matin il y a eu un bombardement qui a
fait un mort
alors avec Monsieur Poutine on ne peut
jamais dire jamais donc il faut être
prudent j'ai pas le sentiment ça me
semble pas être dans son intérêt mais on
a dit ça tellement de fois
c'est on arrive à un point de bascule
dans cette dans cette guerre à mon sens
cette semaine la semaine suivante soit
les forces russes sont capables
d'entretenir le mouvement ce qui est pas
évident parce que je pense que c'est
souffle mais d'un autre côté est-ce que
les Ukrainiens vont encore pouvoir tenir
pendant cette semaine ou pendant 15
jours c'est ça la question quoi et de là
dépendra la suite des événements et
aussi des soutiens que pourraient que
Poutine pourrait avoir de l'extérieur ça
c'est encore un autre sujet oui puisque
militairement les Russes pour l'instant
n'ont pas avancé il y a pas eu d'avancer
majeur en Ukraine on sent que la
l'avancée est très lente et l'un des
proches de Vladimir Poutine là avoué
indirectement aujourd'hui l'avancée
n'est pas aussi rapide que prévu
c'est à dire leur stratégie initiale a
fait défauts ils n'ont pas pu pénétrer
rapidement déstabiliser la population
des stabiliser le pouvoir il y aura eu
un effet domino et l'Ukraine ce serait
écroulé très vite ils ont sous-estimé la
résistance ukrainienne donc maintenant
il se trouve devant une stratégie qu'ils
ont pas vraiment voulu pas vraiment
piloter ils sont dispersés leur force
sont dispersées elles sont tenues par
les encerclements de toutes les villes
que vous avez citées maintenant elles
vont aussi dans l'Ouest pour d'autres
motifs donc il y a une grande dispersion
de l'effort et je on se rend compte que
l'armée russe a aussi sa limite alors
venons-en à ce qu'il s'est passé samedi
les Russes ont envoyé selon les
Ukrainiens une trentaine de missiles de
croisières sur yarovi rive ce site qui
est bombardé à accueillait un centre de
formation et d'entraînement de l'OTAN il
est situé on va peut-être le revoir sur
la carte à une vingtaine de kilomètres
de la Pologne est-ce que c'est un
message selon vous adressé à l'OTAN un
message ou même une menace
oh c'est oui c'est très clair ça c'est
l'OTAN d'abord aux Ukrainiens parce que
ce centre en fait c'est un centre que
les Ukrainiens ont bâti en 1995 ça date
pas d'hier c'était donc post-guère froid
le Partenariat pour la paix avec le
temps en particulier et ça servait
effectivement pour l'effort ukrainien à
se former au standard au meilleur
standard de l'OTAN ce qui leur permet
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui d'utiliser les
armements qu'on leur donne donc il y a
une logique c'est pas pour rien que les
Ukrainiens atteignent le niveau qu'ils
ont aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent se
défendre et en frappant cette base qui
est aussi près de la frontière polonaise
les Russes essayent aussi de tarir le
flux des volontaires qui rejoignent
l'Ukraine parce que a priori il passe
par là aussi sans doute ailleurs mais
par là en particulier parce que c'est un
très beau centre de formation et
d'entraînement et donc ils ont mis le
paquet si je peux dire 30 missiles c'est
pas rien ça veut dire pour bien
comprendre ce site
l'OTAN dispose de base entre guillemets
non militaire en Ukraine non non
ce sont les Ukrainiens qui accueillent
des des personnels des militaires de
l'Otan qui viennent enseigner d'accord
personnels des nations il y a il y a un
couplage avec avec un pays avec un État
des États-Unis je me suis impliqué donc
il y a c'est des partenariats mais ça
appartient aux Ukrainiens le temps n'a
pas de drapeau c'est pas une base de
l'OTAN simplement l'OTAN il vient les
instructeurs de temps viennent pour
instruire les Ukrainiens est-ce qu'il y
a une ligne rouge que les Russes ne
doivent pas franchir vis-à-vis de l'OTAN
ah bah c'est la c'est les frontières les
frontières maritimes aériennes
terrestres c'est ça la ligne rouge pas
un ours on dit le leader de l'OTAN
le président Zelenski ce matin réitère
sa demande de zone d'exclusion aérienne
sinon dit-il les Rockets russes vont
tomber sur l'OTAN on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'un accident qui pourrait
dégénérer
alors on comprend tout à fait le
président ski défense son pays et c'est
normal qu'il soit très véhément mais
d'un autre côté et on l'a déjà expliqué
à de nombreuses reprises vouloir d'une
manière ou d'une autre intervenir dans
l'espace aérien ukrainien ce serait
considéré comme une déclaration de
guerre dans la mesure où la Russie peut
ou pro maîtrise cet espace et donc
l'OTAN les pays de l'OTAN n'ont pas
choisi cette option parce que le risque
d'escalade est trop élevé mais en
revanche ils sont prêts à se défendre et
c'est vrai que la proximité de la
frontière rend l'exercice de défense de
protection de l'OTAN très délicat il ne
faut pas qu'il y ait d'incidents et que
ça soit en particulier les avions de
l'OTAN qui
le produisent mais si un avion russe
pénètre dans l'espace aérien polonais
par exemple il sera pris en charge et
les mesures seront prises contre lui en
fonction de son attitude
revenons à un instant sur la résistance
ukrainienne on voit que les Ukrainiens
sont armés par les occidentaux notamment
est-ce que ils sont formés pour utiliser
ces armes oui alors je suis un peu
expliqué comment ça se passait depuis
80 1995 mais surtout depuis 2014
évidemment après la première crise
ukrainienne il y a eu une recrudescence
de la formation des Ukrainiens qui
auront participé régulièrement à des
exercices j'étais d'ailleurs à l'époque
responsable des exercices de l'OTAN et
donc on a évidemment intégré les
Ukrainiens comme des partenaires des
partenaires je peux vous dire que les
Ukrainiens sont d'excellents militaires
merci Jean-Paul Palomeros pour vous
expliquer un chef d'état-major de
l'armée française de l'armée de l'air et
donc on vous l'a rappelé ancien
commandant suprême des forces alliés de
l'OTAN merci de nous avoir donné votre
sentiment sur France 24
[Musique]